i'm natalie and i'm chloe and we're with
a wild abundance online gardening school
and we're excited to share with you 10
of our favorite vegetables to plant that
will really feed you
winter squash which includes pumpkins
butternuts and buttercups and all
different kinds and shapes and sizes of
squash that you can grow to store over
the winter are an incredible staple crop
not only is the fruit edible but the
seeds are edible and nutritious too
what's more
they sprawl most varieties sprawl and
cover a ton of ground so you can plant
them on the edge of your garden they'll
even climb up trees in some cases and
they can take up space that you wouldn't
otherwise be able to cultivate perhaps
one of the best things is that they're
delicious in sweet and savory dishes
beans are a super rewarding crop to grow
in part because they fix their own
nitrogen so that means they bring
nitrogen into the soil and they can
thrive even in poorer soils there are
lots of different kinds of beans to grow
some for dry beans like the ones i'm
holding in these jars and some for snap
beans or fresh bean pods like these ones
there are also cow peas and garbanzo
beans and lots of different kinds that
grow well in different kinds of climates
dry beans store well dried in jars like
this and green beans can be pickled
frozen or canned
sweet potatoes can produce a huge amount
of nourishing filling food that stores
well after they're cured all through the
winter they also can thrive even in poor
soils that are low in nitrogen
and they're less susceptible to fungal
and viral diseases than white potatoes
which makes them a really great option
especially in warm wet climates one
thing to keep in mind is that they won't
mature if it's very cool if you don't
have a long hot summer so they're better
for warmer areas and less good for cool
areas there are so many varieties to
choose from and grow in your garden
greens are full of nutrients and an
awesome thing to grow because they
mature relatively quickly they've become
kind of the center of a lot of people's
meals these days instead of just being a
side dish often times it'll be
everything over a bed of lettuce or over
a bunch of kale
this is kale which i love to grow this
is natalie which is an awesome variety i
also like to grow cabbage i like to grow
chard beet greens are awesome and then a
lot of edible weeds are fabulous magenta
spring is a type of lamb's quarters
chickweed is awesome callaloo
and then all sorts of cover crops like
winter peas can also be eaten
corn is another incredible staple crop
when i'm talking about corn as a staple
crop i'm talking about field corn or
grain corn like i'm holding here sweet
corn is really more of a snack the
amount of food that you can produce with
corn and even a small garden is
incredible and it stores really well
it's also the only grain that's easy to
process on a small scale you don't need
any machines to process it and when it
comes to heirloom or traditional
varieties of corn there's an incredible
diversity of colors flavors textures
stories and it's much more nutritious
than anything you could buy in the store
zucchini and other summer squash are
enormously productive we've had plants
that yield well over 20 pounds per plant
that's a lot of food it's not just
boring yucky food it's delicious food i
love to fillet these and put them in my
barbecue i like to fillet them and make
zucchini casserole i like to add them to
stir fries they are so incredibly
versatile we do have some pest issues
with them here but
it's just amazing how much food they
produce even so
tomatoes are an amazing thing to grow in
your garden and who doesn't want to grow
tomatoes they're like iconic in the for
the home gardener and i love to eat them
raw with some fresh mozzarella i love to
make sauces and salsas and can them and
store them and then break them out and
be like yeah these are from my tomatoes
that i grew in my garden
so whatever the case is
you can really get a lot of food from
one plant and they're just so delicious
so i really encourage you to grow
tomatoes
garlic is a really fun and easy thing to
grow you take one clove put it in the
ground in the fall and then in the late
spring you have a whole head of garlic
all with relatively little labor in
between it's not only a food but it's
also a medicine it's anti-fungal and
antibacterial and it makes other foods
taste really fabulous
potatoes also known as the enemy of
hunger by chilean poet pablo neruda and
he knew what he was talking about
they're an incredibly productive storage
craft that even your four-year-old and
your grandma will be familiar with and
will want to eat they're also really fun
to dig up so they're a great crop to
grow in a community garden or a family
garden they grow in even cool moist
soils and they're a really good option
especially for northern climates and
places where
other storage crops like sweet potatoes
just won't hack it because there's not
enough peat
other root crops can really add variety
to your meals beets daikon
turnips and parsnips are foods that grow
in the cool weather and they can
generally be stored really well beets
and turnips can be stored just in sand
or in sawdust and daikons can be
fermented to make fabulous kimchi
these plants are really worth growing
and i highly recommend them for your
garden
thank you so much for joining us for 10
vegetables that can really feed you
if you want to learn more about these
incredible nourishing crops we have a
full online class about it that you can
check out along with a bunch of other
cool stuff at
wildabundance.net
good luck with your garden
[Laughter]